happy monday everybody welcome back and
good morning john good morning monica
hi monica are you doing this morning oh
i'm doing great i'm trying to get over
that spelling bee stuff i'm just trying
to wipe it out of my head we all have
the
the spelling and geography be traumas
that we're trying to get over from none
of us
well guys hey i hope you had a great
weekend today on mondays with monica
folks if you have a minute
you might want to check this out we're
talking about lupus which causes the
body to attack
its own tissues and organs and according
to the lupus foundation of america
it affects at least one and a half
million people
here in the u.s not going to get too
deep into it because i want
our guest to get into it herself her
name is amanda green
and amanda became engaged in this fight
because she's a healthcare advocate not
only is she a healthcare advocate for
lupus
she actually has lupus and other
autoimmune conditions
thank you so much for being here amanda
how you doing
i'm doing well monica thank you for
having me happy monday and the same to
you
listen so um i went on your website and
you're a busy woman you're busier than
most doctors that i interview about
these kinds of topics but
first of all tell our viewers what is
lupus and how does it affect people on a
day-to-day
basis because i believe there are two
types right
um actually there's a few types there's
systemic lupus
breath mitosis which is what i have
there's discoid lupus
and there's nephritis which um
it primarily affects the kidneys and i
have systemic lupus which
is involves many organs and every person
with lupus
at least systemic lupus is is different
my friends might be involved for me it
happens to me my
my skin my hair and my
stomach yeah and i wanted to talk about
this amanda because our temperatures
this week
are going like through the roof record
temperatures a lot of folks are coming
here because we're open
100 percent now but being aware of the
sun
wearing the sunscreen taking all the
precautions not only
is it important for you know mainstream
folks it's very important for people
like you
who have lupus and who have other
autoimmune diseases talk about that for
me
well sunscreen is your friend sp you
know be careful with your spfs
um there's you can wear loose light
clothing you can
stay out of the sun it's always a good
idea i know what it's impossible when
you know you you live in nevada but
um the uv rays are harmful um
fluorescent
light can can trigger there's a lot of
things that can trigger a flare and you
want to avoid that so you might want to
avoid the sun you can wear a hat
everybody know you know these are things
whether you have lupus or not
you can wear a hat you can wear um
like i said protective clothing stay in
the shade between the main hours
but it's just when you live with lupus
there's a lot of
adjustments you need to make and the sun
is just one of them
absolutely absolutely and i don't know
if you remember this amanda if you're
old enough to remember this
but uh seal the rocker he used to be
married to heidi klum he really brought
it to the forefront
the skin loop is part of it uh because
he has the scars on his face and
everybody thought you know he's just a
sexy looking guy but
he was on oprah i remember years ago and
he was talking about how it impacted his
life and how he was self
uh self-conscious about it and all that
but there are so many different
things that you can do now there's the
virtual reality headsets there's
lupus pain management talk about those
things for us
definitely well well there's different
everybody needs
to find something that works for them
and since every patient's different for
me what i found
is virtual reality there's a headset
program
that helps you learn to
use your diaphragm to breathe deeper
to be more mindful and by the
you know if you're breathing correctly
it even has to you know the technology
is there so if you breathe correctly and
you're breathing right
a tree will grow the leaves will grow on
a tree the tree will
thrive and it's very relaxing it's very
it's almost like meditative state yeah
and
it's not gonna relieve the pain
completely but if you can be painles
a little less pain is a good thing when
you live with lupus because pain is a
daily
issue yeah yeah and tell me have we have
we gotten better
in terms of how we take care of
ourselves here in
uh in our country when it comes to lupus
because i know back in the day the
numbers were pretty high
especially in certain communities like i
said in particular in the black
community
that you always talked about lupus and
diabetes and sickle cell
has it changed have we gotten better
well well at least with lupus 90
of lupus patients are women wow
and of those a high percentage are women
of color
and african american latina american
um asian americans are there are
actually at more risk and so sometimes
if you're not feeling well
you have to be your own advocate even
before you know
what it is and just say could it be
lupus because a lot of doctors aren't
going to be the first thing they're
going to test you for isn't going to be
lupus
for me i i was tired all the time and
i was a young teenage person and i had
to quit drill team
and so for me they tested me for
mononucleosis
one time yeah yeah and it turned out to
be lupus yeah
well amanda we are out of time i
i would love to get more information for
you from you rather but where can people
go to get more information about this
this condition
well i personally love lupus and allied
diseases association that's at latta
lada
inc dot okay and it's it's a great
organization and
i don't know if um i there's a a lot of
people wear purple capes at lupus walks
and i was
um the originator of the purple cape for
i lupus awareness i live in our way but
it's a little vegas it is a
purple uh latex with a silver sequins
and it says la lupus lady so next time
there's a lupus walk
and we can gather in vegas perhaps
you'll see me there
all right amanda thank you so much we
appreciate it and hey good luck to you
and stay out of the sun my friend i know
it can really have
some pretty bad side effects on you but
thank you for bringing the message to us
we appreciate it thank you
and you can also find me i'm la lupus
lady on twitter and if you have any
questions
reach out to me and i'll i'll help you
connect with
resources in your area thank you so much
monica i really appreciate it all right
we appreciate you too my friend thank
you
and don't forget folks to catch my moj
show facebook live weeknights at 7 p.m